all right i don't like it when new
buttons pop up and that i haven't seen
before
anyway we have people from london
toronto
um washington dc it's great to see
everybody on the on the
webinar today so let's just get started
i told you about myself
and i really like to know what drew you
to attend this session today
so again i'd love to have an interactive
informal session so if you'd be willing
to say
why you chose to attend that would be
great
i'm quite happy to start dying so i can
give
so my background so i've worked in
financial services
as a project manager for about 10 years
based in the city of london moved to
switzerland two years ago
to work in consulting and i've been
doing some training with udacity so i've
done a data visualization course
uh looking to transition into a
data analyst dashboard design
type of profile and also looking to
change the industry so
coming out of the financial services and
looking at other industry
so i get um what i'm trying to figure
out is
what's the best way to leverage your
experience from your previous
um you know life uh into your new career
transition and not having to
start from scratch also how to sort of
leverage some
you know transferable skills that you
may
you know uh learn from new projects um
experience and uh
how to market myself into this
program right that's a common one
how do we make use of our a previous
career as we move into something new and
how
how do we highlight our transferable
skills certainly on my list today to
talk about
so thank you charles who else would be
willing to share why they
signed up today
hello yeah hi this is craig
hi how are you
pretty much the same questions that
charles the charles have
um i'm 40 now
almost 41 uh years old i live in the
dominican republic
and i've been developing software since
the
late 90s uh
you know technology is a very
competitive
sector uh we have now a bunch of new
areas and many many young people
uh which we have to
be you know at the same level
so at some point um
you me
get tired to be you know trying to be at
the same level of
guys of twenties and um
most of my my
uh fellow students at university
they moved to usa or other countries uh
they moved to a lot top level now
i started uh another degree
i am not planning to move from the
technology
sector to the area
do something different instead of just
developing software
uh
not administrative but something
more to try to add more value maybe
to start my my um business uh
or to be a level i
can be more like a consultant or
something like that
that's that's what i i what i would like
to know is
well the same question that charles how
to do that transition
the less pain uh painless weight
okay okay that makes perfect sense so i
think there are
many people who are doing what you're
doing and i hear that
um opening a line as you gave me
you talked about your age and you're
still relatively young
but i think many of us feel um
it's it's very common to feel like we
are competing with a much younger
workforce
um with who who many have
excellent technology skills and so we're
looking to
do this transition in the least painful
way right
okay thank you for sharing that all
right
so so we're going to go ahead and kind
of jump
into the presentation today
again i'd like this to be not just me
giving
insight but having others of you
give your insight and your experience
because it's very relevant i mean
this is something that's helpful to
share with each other
what our experience has been so that was
what i was hoping for today
um so we'll go ahead and and move into
the agenda we're gonna
talk about um you know some of the
common challenges that we all face
uh come up with some ideas and share
some ideas for overcoming those
challenges
and and as some of you said you know you
want to know how to leverage what you
have in your career you don't want to
throw that out
how can you make use of some of the very
strong
skills that you have and and experiences
you have and how can you leverage that
as you move into a new realm
okay all right so um
just in terms of getting this
conversation going
um i'd like to know maybe in
one or two words from each person um
whether you choose to share on this
chat or if you um will unmute yourself
just give me two one or two words of the
challenge you feel like you're
facing
so if i can i think relevant experience
it's not just experience but actually
relevant experience into the new role
sometimes you know something that comes
up a lot
okay very true thanks charles
someone else um this is monadi from
london and
i think i agree with charles as well uh
that's what my experience has been
um that we have a lot of experience but
the relevant experience is the
um exact category where we uh seem to be
lacking a lot okay okay great mundi
thank you so much
who else
one challenge you feel like you're
facing
oh not okay i'm sorry not knowing
exactly which field to go to next
yeah uncertainty about you know what's
the best option
for yourself that makes that makes sense
and
that's something we can talk about today
in terms of um
you know finding that area where we can
excel
and bring our past experience to bear
daniela also agrees with lack of
relevant experience
ah salary there it is i was hoping
someone would bring that up
uh we've been we'll talk about salary
today
something that's a better fit excellent
yeah
yeah you know at this time in our lives
when we um
when we decide to make a change or a
change is forced upon us
which sometimes is the case right um
what we want to do with that is
hopefully shift into something where
you know we can really enjoy the rest of
our career
do something we really love okay
lack of professional network with
industry practitioners
[Music]
very key that networking part is so
important lauren says whether there are
certain areas where a relevant academic
degree is required
i had that question just this morning
with a client
do i need to go back to school and get a
master's in computer science
um those kinds of questions are out
there
you know when is my experience enough to
offset the need for a degree all right
well thank you thank you for sharing and
it's not too late
i have another guest waiting i'll go
ahead and invent them
okay all right just a second here
i think we'll go ahead and
lock the meeting there we go all right
that way i can focus all right
okay so let's get into the discussion
and i think you all hit on most of these
um common challenges that we face at
career transition time
and you know this can apply in the
beginning of a career too
all of these things many of these things
can apply but these are more common
for those of us who are making a change
um at the midlife area and that's a wide
range of ages i i don't think there's a
particular
age that we can consider midlife but
um i sort of categorize it as the time
period after you've worked for a while
okay and maybe you've worked in a
certain industry and
um and then you're looking to make a
shift and that shift might be very
subtle
um meaning you just tweak some things
about what your
focus is um or it could be very drastic
um you know people coming from a
non-technical area
into a technical area that could be that
could be a pretty drastic change
okay so what do you all think about the
list that i have here
any of these um particularly stand out
as something you want to make sure we
talk about today
yeah sure okay
okay ashraf okay which which one of
these resonates
with you the most uh for me personally
over under qualified okay okay great
all right
personal values aligning with
responsibility of the new role
and confidence okay yeah you know
that that's so true what i hear from a
lot of students
um really is that the reason they're
making a change
is because they want to have a different
impact on the world
on their community um let me just
take a minute and ask that question um
you know the very first question i have
on this slide is
explaining why to your new employer or
or maybe even to your colleagues um
so let me ask you your why
who would be willing to share why very
briefly
why you want to change your career
i guess in my case um it's
wanted to make an impact um
on a different level um so changing
industry changing role
um to actually make an impact
so if i were to ask you you feel like
you feel like your previous career maybe
didn't have the kind of
impact that aligns with personal values
or was it something
else yeah sort of video okay
okay yeah oftentimes it is the personal
value
reason um so so great thanks for sharing
who else
might give me um a quick
why they're making a change
sometimes the feeling of missing out on
another opportunity or like you feel
that there is there is something more
to do than your current job okay
and more to do like maybe in terms of
purpose
exactly okay okay yeah yeah
i mean and let's be honest i i think at
least in my
experience as we you know
move up chronologically is that a good
way to say we get older
um we often times um
place more value on having an impact in
this world
uh having a purpose something that
really drives
us to you know get up in the morning and
and do something as a vocation that
doesn't feel like work
and the reason it wouldn't feel like
work is because we love it and we're
really making a difference so that's not
uncommon
um particularly at midlife
anybody else want to share their why
uh frederick
in my case uh i really love what i do
um and i feel that i'm a great company
it's it's been growing since all this
just what is happening now in the world
um
but i've been in my in my industry
this technology i've been since the
beginning
giving like branches i first started in
the
uh working as part of us of the
insurance company i was working that
in that field for for a while then i
moved to the telecommunications
sector in my area
of course and now i am in a different
sector
which is more which is more interesting
but and i've been
in one company for four years that
that's that's a big deal because i never
took more than two years in it in a
company uh but
there are a bunch of new employees
um young people
uh with i think they
i feel it or they are
faster learners or i am getting
uh i don't know i don't know if it's
if it's had something to do with that i
am
growing family and have more
more more thoughts uh more concerns
but i don't feel that i am solving
problems
as fast as they do and as i
use it to do
also uh one of the fields that i am
interested in
is uh the machine learning area
uh i've been trying to to
uh investigate i love research and
uh what i'm doing now is
just like more like a mechanical
procedures and he can get
uh quite boring okay so i hear
thank you for sharing that frederick i
hear you want to continue to do
interesting work and you want it to be a
good fit for
where you're at in your life um you you
want to continue to do
problem solving it sounds like that's an
area where you're um
maybe recognizing a change but
but um you still have um a sincere
interest in being of value so we're
going to talk about
um that and i think you know you you did
a nice job of
kind of covering a lot of ground uh for
us today about
the reasons and one of the things that
will become very important
as each of you tell your story um
about why is to figure out how to
present that
in a way that is engaging and gets the
interest and piques the interests
so you're going to tell your story in a
number of different places
you're going to tell it on linkedin
you're going to talk about it in your
cover letter
each of those messages is going to be
slightly different
you're going to be prepared to talk
about it in an interview
you want to practice your elevator pitch
with your colleagues so it
becomes kind of a natural story that
you can feel comfortable talking about
so thank you so much for sharing
all right okay so we got some some
input on why and as as
expected each one of us has a different
reason for making a change
so um you know
i think that it's important for us to
hit some of these that you all brought
up
and so i think i want to make sure
before we run out of time that we
talk about relevant experience
so let me do this let me put this back
out to the group
um who here on the session today
has had an experience translating
their past um skills and talents
and gifts into something related to
their new career
who's had that experience and who could
share i
some ideas with us
anyone
monitor yes hi monitor hey
um so uh so i'm i'm a software engineer
and um
i've been uh picking up machine learning
one of the challenges that i've had is
of course as a software engineer i've
i have the background of and the skill
of writing programs
um but one of the challenges is to be
able to showcase that
uh you know you know ability right
program
somehow also is very very
um uh you know
not applicable but very crucial for a
machine learning engineering position as
well because
if i look at the um let's say a
distribution of other candidates
obviously someone applying to a machine
learning position would also have coding
background as well so how do i
differentiate myself
using my skills that i already have to
really stand out because at the end of
the day it's a machine learning
one right machine learning position so
and that's where i have
just started so that's where i feel i am
lacking in a way to make that successful
career transition okay okay so let me
ask you this question
in your software engineering background
um what what what's
one key thing that made you the most
successful
uh problem solving uh the ability to
uh to take a a problem and be able to
solve it
uh basically transform it into a
technical way so that you know
take a business problem and translate it
into a a pro
a way to program something and solve
that out
and then how does that same thing relate
to machine learning uh
it it kind of does from an overall
perspective you know you have to solve
the problem
uh per se but machine learning
the overall way of thinking and machine
learning is a little bit different
wherein we instead of writing a program
you would now focus on the data to
let the program learn from the data so
that's a different paradigm
of thinking towards problem solving
and well i
while this is some obviously an acquired
skill
you pick up along the way um and i have
been doing that but
but to showcase that experience in doing
that
right i think that's where uh
i've been lacking a bit of i i feel it's
that's fair as a challenge for me
uh of course i've done projects uh side
projects but
the lack of uh industry experience if i
can say that
is somewhere you know i feel i
tend to get behind other candidates who
may be applying to the same position
okay okay so um let me just
ask the group anyone have suggestions
for monadi
i told you this is going to be
interactive
well i have almost the same problem as
okay okay all right maybe maybe all
we need to suggest okay okay
okay here's um mk yep to everyone do a
project
based on open source data sets
yeah i think uh something i can also
suggest
from you know what helped me with my
transition is
uh actually joining online communities
uh and and you know creating projects so
i think for software development just
having a
really good github uh profile and
actually
you know work on you know open source
projects
and you know build a portfolio to
actually save
um i've got experience of uh you know
work
uh i've done in that space so that's
something i've been doing with the
tableau community sort of joining the
tableau community
there's a lot of uh you know on twitter
there's a lot of
um weekly challenge you can do with
various data sets
and you know you can learn from other
people as well so i think the
online community side is surely a
really good way to you know ramp up your
profile
with that new skill sets
excellent thanks for sharing that
charles
so getting out there and trying out your
skills the other one
and i'm curious to know how how you all
feel about
actually getting out and doing some
freelance work in your
new field
yeah that is that is one of the
suggestions that i've gotten from uh
one of my other friends as well so yes
that is
that is something that i'll have to take
up okay
okay yeah yeah and it can be a little
bit frightening to put yourself out
there i think that's
something we might many of us share is
you know will i actually have what it
takes to get that freelance work
um but those are real world experiences
that you can add to your portfolio
the other one that comes up that i've
heard suggested and i've suggested to
clients
is to get out there and volunteer your
new skills
to businesses to non-profits
to other entities who might benefit
from your new skills many of them are in
a difficult
situation right now you can offer some
limited
term project work either for
no pay or low pay and
i don't know how that resonates with
some of you
i think at least for me uh it resonates
pretty well
with just one question i mean would
is there um an aggregator
sigh or something where people do
sponsor their
this non-profit kind of work or uh
i mean if anyone knows that would be
great otherwise i'll definitely do my
research online
um works really well for that um
you know i've seen a lot afraid of you
know people from
you know various experiences who say i'm
you know data
scientist i want to offer my um
you know new skills to any business and
then just having people to share
and you know those things they can have
a huge
snowball effect so i think linkedin is a
good um
platform for that
okay there are actually there is a
volunteer site in the states
i don't know where are you from you're
from toronto
i'm from uh london oh i'm sorry okay
so so but i do think linkedin can either
so many ways to search linkedin and to
use it
um you know just to try to identify um
you know entities that might be looking
at
particularly if you start with groups
you can
you know try non-profit groups you can
look for incubators
that kind of thing and look for people
who are affiliated with those kinds of
entities that where you might you know
small businesses
in your local area sometimes looking
locally even if you're doing remote work
is a good idea
people may feel a different level of
trust
if they know that they could actually
meet with you perhaps
if it was safe to do so so
okay right thanks for the suggestions
okay
well thank you for being willing to
share your challenge and thanks to
everyone for the input
um in the interest of time we are going
to move on to
some other topics um uh one of the
things that comes up
is the over under qualified um issue
um it's um you know it's one of those
things where
um you know you feel like you have a lot
to offer
and you come into this transition uh
having attained a certain level
uh either in salary or title or both
and a certain level of autonomy and
responsibility
and then you find yourself in a
situation where you
barely meet the qualifications of the
new role
and um you know it can be challenging
um so so really you know
one of the key things that i recommend
is that
you spend a lot of time with the
job descriptions and if you're if you
know let's say you're trying to go into
consulting or trying to open your own
business
you can still use job postings and job
vacancy announcements to help you
determine what the typical requirements
are
in that particular role um
so you know going out and doing what you
know some structure
job description research pulling four or
five job
um vacancy announcements
in that field and um identifying some
common themes in terms of what kinds of
skills they're asking for
and then figuring out where you are in
terms of your own skills
meeting those needs um the thing that
um i recommend that you focus on in this
situation
are your soft skills okay many
of the jobs will ask for things like
problem solving
and conflict resolution ability to work
on
teams good communication skills
um typically those are things that
you know we've had experience with in
our previous careers
and that's where you leverage your um
yourself as an asset thinking about
examples
where you excelled in those areas
writing those examples
down so that they're easier to recall
when you're speaking in an interview
or you're you know maybe
talking about um your past experience in
a cover letter
um you know reframe those situations
um if you've had an excellent example of
where you were part of a team and a
conflict came up and
or a big problem you know talk about the
role that you played
recall what you did that was unique in
that situation
how did you help move things along and
those are very important and you know
being in the hr role for
many years i was involved in many many
searches
and you know the behavioral questions
were
big at least in the hr world
those are the ones where we really
assess suitability for positions
and yes the technical skills were
important and i don't want to minimize
that particularly
in the technology fields but
really you know spending some time ahead
of time
thinking about those soft skills that
you have
and how those translate into the new
uh skill requirements is really
important
so i'm going to stop talking now and ask
for comments on that point
or concerns or questions
anyone okay
all right okay
um do we want to talk about ageism
what do you think is it real or imagined
can you make us
this is monitor i i i haven't faced
ageism but i think
um i think it's not an imaginary one i'm
pretty sure it's
it is it is faced okay okay
great so so here are some things i want
to and i'm going to i have a slide on
this
probably have other slides but i really
wanted us to kind of
uh let me get to that
like just a second
okay talked about explaining the why
okay
so here here's my spiel on ageism yes it
it can happen and it's
um for the most part out of our control
as to how
um hiring managers
determine how much this factors in okay
um so i think that
uh what you the best thing is to focus
on what you can
control and this is another thing where
you spend
quite a bit of time ahead of time
thinking about you know what is it about
your place in life your age if you want
um your experience that's brought you to
this point
that makes you an asset um
and you know what is it you're competing
with um
so so when i think about those things
the things the attributes that come to
mind
are on this slide um be a person
that shows flexibility um if you are
open to new ideas
you've had experience with change if
you've worked for any length of time
at any employer you you've had changes
that have that have uh caused you to
have to
adapt um and so think about a time when
you
did that and how you did that um
keep your skills up to date and i doubt
that anybody on this call
has that challenge uh i think many of
the udacity
students are in a good place um because
they are willing to learn new skills and
keep their
um you know be up on leading technology
but you also need to do your research um
you know
read a lot get out there and and read
blogs or write your own blog
stay up on the latest it's very
important for the employer to see that
you know you don't have your head in the
sand that not only
are you demonstrating by taking a
udacity course
or other courses to keep your skills up
to date that you're actually
active out in that industry
okay um you know use your experience as
an
asset think about you know what it is
about
you at this point in time that
would make you an asset to a future
employee
um being willing to do what it takes
um you know coming you know it's easy to
think okay i've worked 20 years in my
career
i've attained a certain level of
professionalism
certain job responsibilities
might be beneath me i'm i'm
going to assume that none of you have
that mindset but if you do
and it's and it's not in common uh
challenge yourself on that
uh be able to give examples of in the
past where you were willing to
step out of your role and help someone
complete a project or you know prop
problem solve outside of the scope of
your job
um you know demons anything where you
can demonstrate that you're
resilient and you bounce back
and and you know primarily staying
positive is a very important thing to do
when you're
in the interview and you're talking with
employers
so if so if you could take this list
and prior to an interview think about
examples of
where you did this those would be great
examples to have
in your back pocket when you go for an
interview
as an employer that's what i would be
looking for
it would matter less to me about
someone's age
and more about how they were resilient
and flexible and they had a learning
mindset
so i'll stop there and ask for reactions
and thoughts
and challenges to what i've said
i think it makes sense uh because
as as someone who would have you know
spent
years on a different technology on a
different
uh way of doing things if you're moving
to another field another company you
would always
want to uh the new employee to be
in line with the company culture the way
you know things are done in the new
uh field so that way i think yeah it
makes sense to be
flexible and adaptable um to the new
situation to the new technology to the
new role
altogether because at the end of the day
it
you will have to work with your team in
a very competitive manner and if you
can't do that
i think uh you won't be able to help
your team and the company move forward
any other thoughts thank you monique
so these are the things that we can
control we can't really
control how the hiring manager makes
their decision but we certainly can
you know play up this aspect of our past
career
and show that um you know we're not
locked in in our mindset we're not done
learning
those things are very important so okay
any other comments
hey let's talk about salary uh
let me find my salary slide
where do we go here
i don't know where it went sorry
oh it's right here okay just to finish
uh
sorry diane on the yeah yes
do you know that's something i was um
actually joining some
some workshop with uh you know people in
the you know mid 50s etc and
i was surprised that people would um
you know introduce themselves and say um
you know i'm
50 odd years and work in a company etc
i think there's probably a stigma i
think that's a society stigma that
now if you unemployed and in your 50s
you fall into that bucket uh but that's
something you can challenge you know
yourself and i think
um you know touchwood i don't know well
being
when i'm in my mid 50s but um all that
experience you know all that you know
maturity there's a lot of things you can
leverage from a
younger generation so um you know
learning new skills and you know
adapting i think you know everything
you've listed that's
you know what you know help so i think
um
you know there's probably like a huge
stigma on aj but
you know it's not you know something i
think you can overcome that
as any other challenges thank you for
sharing that perspective charles
yeah absolutely um i think i think we
get
fearful about those things because they
are stigmas and we know
we've heard examples and horror stories
of other people who
maybe have experienced something like
that um
so thank you for sharing that
okay so let's talk quickly about salary
as we're kind of running out of time
um you know i think this is something
that
there are several things i'll comment on
salary
um as you're moving into a new field it
it makes sense to spend a little time
researching the salary expectations
um i think sometimes people um
you know don't realize how important it
is to have realistic
expectations on salary and it is one of
the
key challenges of moving into a
different
field um sometimes you might end up
in a field where the salary
possibilities are greater than you've
ever had before so that's
a different situation but it's not
uncommon
to especially after working 15 20 years
in a certain field
to have risen to the level where you're
making a pretty decent salary you have a
pretty high level responsibility
and um and then now you're making a
change
maybe it was a change that was brought
upon you or maybe you made a conscious
choice to move into a different industry
or a different
area so doing some salary research
on the internet even to kind of get a
sense of what are the salaries
and then going ahead and applying for
some jobs and see what the salary offers
are but
talking to some people who are in the
field on linkedin
trying to make some connections getting
a ballpark range of salaries for the new
job
um you know and then you have to ask
yourself
can i realistically bear
this kind of a salary and if you can't
you need to get creative you either
change what
you're going after or you need to think
about cobbling together a couple of
things
maybe you're working a part-time gig to
supplement
while you move into a salary range and
then give yourself some time for growth
um but um another thing that's
i think really important is it you know
many people do have salary flexibility
um i've heard from many who say you know
i've got some flexibility for this
reason or that
and what they're worried about most is
the employer
thinking they don't right and mk
asks is there a way to negotiate a
higher salary in the field by leveraging
your experience we'll talk about that in
a minute but
um i think you don't want to let an
employer's fear
about you wanting to be paid too much
money get in the way
so what you can do in that case
is be knowledgeable about the salary
um the market salary uh
ranges um and if you
feel like um you know
a hiring manager might anticipate for
some reason that you
would need a higher salary it's okay to
bring that up
and you can do it diplomatically in a
cover letter even
there are ways to word it based on you
know
i realized that you know given my past
experience
there could be some concern about my
salary flexibility
and i i wanted to let you know that
the most important thing to me in this
job transition is
moving into an area where i can
have a greater impact and that
um to offset this i am certainly open to
um you know negotiating salary something
like that that's not a perfect statement
that you get the drift of what i'm
saying
um it's okay to bring that up if you
think
hey you came from a field where the
salaries are very high
you're moving into a different role you
realize the salary might be lower and
sometimes that can make the difference
uh between you getting put in the yes
pile
at an interview screening uh or not
thoughts on that
um yeah i guess you know the way i try
to approach those you know um
difficult discussion is uh looking at
the range
as well so you know let the recruiter
you know assess based on your experience
and really
sort of you know embodying everything
we've discussed in terms of transferable
skills
and you know the value you add from your
experience
but also looking at you know what is
outside just the financial package
because uh you know there can be a lot
of additional perks
uh training pensions and any other
things
that you know would actually come as
part of the package and
and sometimes you know not you know
hitting that
uh you know net salary or you know um
discussion by actually looking at what
else there is you know
and we might you know see some other
perks that
you know would have um you know also
their benefits so
i you know actually looking at at that
side and that sort of
you know makes the salary discussion you
know more bearable
i think absolutely thank you so much for
bringing that point up
that's absolutely appropriate in this
circumstance to look at the whole
package
and i do find that most many people
making a change already do have some
idea about the salary level so i think
it's
um you know doing a little bit more work
to make sure you understand the whole
package is really important
okay so mk ask a question about
negotiating a higher salary in a new
field by leveraging your experience
absolutely and that's part of the
discussion
um i mean you're gonna put your best
self forward in your
cover letter and your interview um
you know in a sort of indirect way it's
your job to point out
why you would be an asset in this role
um
and talk about how your past experience
translates into the new field
why is it that they should hire you
why will you be an asset in that role to
that company
and it's your job to connect the dots
for that employer
and by doing this in advance
you make you set yourself up if there is
a possibility of negotiating a higher
starting salary
you've already laid the groundwork for
that and i'm not saying in every
opportunity you can always negotiate
higher
but if you lay the groundwork well in
the interview process and all the stages
leading
up to that you have a much better chance
of pushing
for a slightly higher salary okay
all right okay so i do want to hit on
um a couple of other things i think
someone brought up the networking and
not being connected in the network as
well
in the industry and really you have a
lot of control over that
getting out there and acting as if you
are already
in the industry and i don't mean that in
a misleading way
but starting to connect with people who
are doing the kind of work that you want
to be doing at the companies you might
want to work for
and joining the professional groups
uh starting to look at what people are
writing and not just
liking the things that people are
writing about but actually adding an
additional comment
you want to do it in a genuine and
authentic way
um and you don't want to do it every
time but
in order to get noticed in the industry
you need to be active
out on linkedin and some of your other
um
connections um attending
uh events that are in your industry
whether it's on eventbrite or some other
meetup groups
um you know this is an area where people
are
um maybe not maximizing their
opportunity as as often it's a lot of
work
but it's well worth it it pays off um
you know it's that act as if you know
really means that it looks like you are
already doing that
in some way so other thoughts and other
ideas along this line
yeah i think everything you've listed oh
but you know sorry frederick but um
just quickly so everything you've listed
die and make sense
um you know join the online communities
um that is relevant to you um you know
new skill set or new career and then
you'll build up a network very quickly
yeah it's it's really worthwhile i tell
my clients to
carve out um a little bit of time
each day or three times a week to
actually get in the habit
of cultivating this network spend time
growing your network each day
and spend time working the network um
you know it's it you know it's
it's very important there are a lot of
aspects to this career transition
and you absolutely need to spend time on
all of them but you must carve out some
time for the networking piece
and this needs to become a lifelong
habit this
isn't about just when i'm looking for a
job this is about a way of being
in the world especially nowadays with
social media so prevalent it's very
important that you get comfortable in
this space
and and and then as things start to open
up safely
um don't be afraid to get out there in
person and
and do the same thing uh it's very
important
um and you can be a help to others as
well
so um so on that point and we are
running out of time
um are there any uh just burning
questions that we didn't get to today
that
you'd like to bring up
i don't have a question but just to
point out that
what you said um
one of the key things in
when moving to a different area uh as
i told i started working and insurance
then to telecommunicate
and one of the things that help
is to try as you said to find
communities
uh at least in
in the area in the technology area
there are a lot of events uh now they
are
online um but
uh there are always
the technology people there is always uh
eager to help if you want to have a
question or if you want to
to connect to a community uh communities
are all
sometimes separated or splitted by by
by language programming language or by
by technology machine learning for
example
uh there are many you will be always
uh welcome
uh if you have the the it
it can be challenging for some people
who
is uh you know
doesn't have this social abilities they
to to communicate with others but if
you want to or at least if you try
uh to ask someone to help you you can be
sure
that they will that's great experience
yes that's an excellent point and i
think we
we've all kind of learned that by trial
and error so thank you for mentioning
that it really kind of
helps people feel more comfortable to
approach others
um and that kind of segues into the last
question
that was asked you know how about
creating opportunities and i framed this
slide
exactly that way for a purpose
you might have noticed my first bullet
on the first slide said find
opportunities
i'm a firm believer in that
we can create opportunities and we
create them
in a number of ways we first start with
a
with envisioning the ideal for ourselves
spend some time dreaming and um
write down what you think you know ask
yourself the question if i could create
the ideal scenario to use my new skills
and move into the area i want to move
what would that look like
what would i be doing what would that be
called
who would i be doing it for um
and really push yourself on the dream
and write it down
um and then take elements of that and
start to do searches
do open-ended searches on the internet
find out which fields are in demand now
how can your particular skills
fit into that industry um
you know can't can your chosen
profession apply in that field
uh reach out to people uh find people
who might
be potential partners talk about the
possibilities
never know where that might end up in
terms of an opportunity for you
and then get creative and how you
use your skills we talked about
freelancing and creating your own
internship is still a possibility and
reaching out to volunt organizations
that could use
volunteers and demonstrating your skills
join groups that pertain to your skills
and
and the industry you're interested in
read what they're writing
follow the influencers go to events
and find people who are doing what you
would like to be doing and find out how
they made the transition
um now one thing that people sometimes
overlook and are afraid to push the
boundaries is if they're employ
say they've been employed with an
employer for a while
and they want to make a shift in their
career but it's still related to the
field that they're
in uh talk to people in
positions of influence and power at your
um employer ask about you know share
your goals
ask about you know maybe i'm interested
in doing this and i realize we have
another department that does that work
how could i um you know how could i move
into that area what
what's possible for me and it doesn't
work all the time
but if you're making a transition if you
can do it at a current
employer that you've had good success
with that's all the better and then
maybe you move on from there or maybe
not
maybe you stay with that employer so
anyway
so i really enjoyed this time with you
you all have
um a wealth of information to offer and
i really appreciated the interaction
and the sharing and so um i hope that
we i know we barely scratched the
surface on a few things so i apologize
for that but i
hope that you leave this session with
some new ideas
and that's the whole point of today is
to
challenge your thinking and hopefully
you'll come up with some
um some actions from what happened today
that will push you
forward
thank you very much that was very useful
very insightful
and thank you to the the team as well to
share the experience
you know it's always good to interact in
that way
thank you charles for your always for
your participation
great everybody stay safe and
and um and well
sure thanks dan thank you all right
thank you
thanks everyone
thank you very much oh you're welcome
thank you for your participation
frederick
thank you thank you bye